herzlich willkommen meine damen und
dick anrufen sondern wir selber können
sitze ich aber auch nicht hier um zu
geht darum dass die politik einfach
es gäbe eine große friedenskonferenz mit
was mir an dieser
noch mal anders wie lösen wir das auf
wir das nicht wollen und ich bin die
weiß man auch nicht ob der irgendwo
verlautbarungen der politik zu
präsidenten beiden ja der dritte
heute abend sein wird
keine
weiß das muss man sich mal vorstellen
herren bei 14 85 köpfen fünf meinungen
unterschiedlichen lebens nun mit der
jetzt so ein bisschen frauen sind männer
sagen also man ist jetzt sozusagen die
ja auch noch dafür tun ja indem wir
ist durch weißig 293 ja einen armen
deutschen haben kein vertrauen mehr in
erste die das nicht will und habe das
zuvor schwesig also zumindest zu ihrer
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
irgend jetzt ist ja sowieso nicht mehr
hinterfragen
etwas machen bevor wir also alle jetzt
nein nein das bin ich dabei nicht fand
und das heißt das denn dann jetzt für
weltkrieg muss verhindert werden also
kriegsberichterstattung tatsächlich seit
ohne kinder kümmern sich um diese frage
unmenschliche arbeitsbedingungen
sind vom mars frauen sind von dem
minister gott sei dank ja aber wir haben
der menschen gehabt dass bei den eiern
panik haben und nicht glaube das ist ein
verantworten muss sie zurücktreten eine
ich meine es gibt ja vorschläge ohne
zeit und wir wollen hier nach frau groos
staat und regierung er nur regierung 16
vegan leben damit seien sehr raucher so
herren bei 485 köpfe fünf meinungen
nämlich einfach unser verhalten ändern
auch schon in anderen fernsehsendungen
die ukraine und sie sagt ja auch ich
so ist das nenne ich habe mich heute
diesen auftritt auch da bin ich auch bei
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
halten das heißt das was ich
beginn was mich auffällig stört ist ein
teilweise hat weil natürlich viele also
wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr aber eltern
regierung ja es wurde dann zum beispiel
ende 32 stunden woche für frauen
experten mit politikern mit psycho mit
rettung für frankreich manchmal kommen
tatsächlich ganz große skandale skandale
ganze menge andere politiker auch
meinung hören ob sie denn für die
irgendwie oder wieder heraus in zweifel
gesagt wenn wir das nicht wollen dann
dem kohle uns heimat dass dieser
was ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
vorfeld ihnen ja ankündigen um ihn dann
weiß nicht ob wir dann noch in der nato
indem wir andere kosmetik produkte
thematisiere ist sozusagen die darin
einkommen eigene staaten
auch schon geschafft
prozent haben noch vertrauen in die
ist auch problematisch hat die soziale
viel zu sagen
dienstagabend und vier spannende
über diesen auftritt von olaf scholz
werden es tun denn die erleben dieses
das ist ein problem das die politik
elterngeld was auch immer ich glaube es
ich nenne es mal moralischer überschuss
auftritt im grunde wie sie haben gesagt
sind was heißt das denn nach so und dann
übrigens oracle sie dürfen hier brutal
herzlich willkommen zurück nach schön
da kann ich einen lauterbach und nicht
ist das ziel den krieg zu beenden die
zu verhindern wie auch immer mir fehlt
familien quote ist also erst mal würde
in denen auch millionen sozusagen
weil sie schon ist das freiland ist das
diese klimaschutz stiftung gegründet
dass man die larven an der art und weise
kaufen oder ich finde was a la viva im
frage vernachlässigt mein punkt hier ist
der ganz alle wünschen und die total
problem ja einfach jeden tag und ich
coaches mit eine riesengroße konferenz
sein sie dürfen aber
nicht sagen ja also ich glaube auch wenn
gegründet haben und
wahnsinnig geärgert die ausgelegten muss
regierung regierung ist schlimmer als
lassen sie werden im endeffekt immer
ja also krieg ist immer tragisch das ist
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
ist viel passiert es muss noch mehr
der mann dominiert ja noch die politik
waffen nieder und dann reden wir darüber
in der gesamten sprache die ich seit
der eine satz noch und der ist für
lösen muss denn diese versuche diese
volksvermögen twens zu formulieren
dass sie dran geblieben sind und wir
so nicht revanchieren
ich sagen diese diskussion hat eine ganz
staat aber dass wir sozusagen noch ein
logan
das übersetzt wird wissen die ukraine
passieren aber es ist nicht nur die
zu füllen nachgefolgt ich freue mich
deutschland natürlich relevant sie hat
machen nun direkt weiter mit ihr wollen
wie wir das möglich machen wir hatten
sexy hat ist das leiden dieser rein
noch das günstigste produkt kaufen oder
denke dass sich menschen die betroffen
das schwierige an dieser wahl ist dass
käfighaltung oder sonst was nicht besser
wie es designt war als nicht
einiger zeit als ich sag mal tendenziell
das ist aber andere leblich auch
ganz schlimm was dort passiert auch ich
möchte wo wir als bürgerin darüber
und er hat endlos zeit für endlose
starke generell und dynamik ja wir sind
grundsätzliches institutionen vertrauen
dann wollte man was für das klima tun
der antisemitismus ist in
vor zwei drei tagen ein zeitungsartikel
immer noch nicht was wir tun insofern
ich sagen warum hat er diese
politik und am ende glaube ich sonst
ampel vegan ist uns extra bereich um
tierversuche sind ja trotzdem mit
sehr heute abend hier im studio begrüßen
des friedens und dazu wird putin
was sie gerade wie heißt du hast mir
die verhandlung in der türkei sorgen
europäisches projekt designt und
sind immer mehr einsetzen werden als
gucke mir die bilder an aber der
war das 1 1 ein bisschen durch gehört da
beweist ihre these und hier muss ich ihn
betrogen wurden ja mit mit ganz
beide darf das sagen über 50 jahre und
veröffentlicht ja da steht drin wenn sie
haben dass haben bei uns nur 33 prozent
es eigentlich keine wahl ist ja und zwar
zurücktreten
das auge ist aber niemand von den
hatte er hat hier die meinung von paul
pressekonferenz überhaupt gegeben das
das war aber nur ein vorwand ist eine
eskalierend wahrnehme fehlt mir einfach
aus der sendung raus auf die bereits mit
auch individuen lass mal gucken annalena
sitzungen und ich finde es geht um die
zu dürfen moll und moderatorin alena
deswegen diese sozusagen der fokus dass
diese woche lange
irgendeiner form erforderlich um die
dass er tatsächlich noch nicht auf guten
news an der konsumiert sondern du kannst
schon zum zweiten mal das nämlich
verraten vor der sendung hat diese these
gewählt wird möchte sie hat es sogenannt
da gibt es eine ganze menge und bevor
eingeladen weil was würde er denn dann
frankreich sehr groß die
bin ich völlig bei ihnen also ich fand
jüngere frauen reagieren da anders ich
ihrer forderung ich glaube die würden
199 hackfleisch ja das muss man sich
moralische überschuss und dieses gefühl
das reden über frieden denn was mir noch
nicht mehr in frankreich sind es über 60
durchsichtigen machenschaften und die
war am ende selbst gerecht das war
dementsprechend war für nicht
baerbock auch zwei kleine mädchen ja
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
gerber die ungewöhnlich für ihre
eigentlich immer nur dieses system
diese pressekonferenz auch mit nicht
jetzt eine deutsch russische geschichte
unbedenklichkeit gewisse kosmetik
hier alle unterstützen und wir wünschen
sind und ich spüre schon
schon für emotionen gesorgt bei uns
daumen dass man sagt
die deutsch-französische scheidung wäre
dass wir unter dem massiven druck von
ja auch zum beispiel kein fleisch essen
wir jetzt auch sierau frauen es gab ja
geschlechterspezifisch und ich würde
kollision entsteht dass da einer jetzt
reißt im moment irgendwie munter durch
fremdenfeindlichkeit
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
überzeugend und ein bisschen
habe zwei kinder als alleinerziehende
kommen das ist ja die frage immerhin das
anhand dieser pipeline festgemacht wird
arrogant wie er dort aufgetreten ist auf
aber
wahnsinn in frankreich sind zwei drittel
sind alle noch am abend und das halte
nicht ganz klar ist ist was sind
diskutanten ja mit dem rücktritt von
wie können wir wie können wir die
berufsgruppe nie davor zurückschreckt
schuh erschienen das sehe ich auch aber
ihnen einen schönen abend und morgen
produkte zu garantieren die eigentlich
auch viele die für diese pipeline mit
ja also wir einmal sich wirklich mit dem
emotionen handeln und große strategische
durchgemogelt und die ukraine wir wissen
stream zwei weiter finanziert werden und
trotzdem also was manche menschen können
die weltgeschichte da ist jetzt auch
aber jetzt sagen wir machen direkt
mutter in den neunziger jahren in ulm
sicher das ja das würde ja weil das die
die eine phobie ging gegenüber muslime
eigentlich die kriegsziele also die
sozusagen den ich mag rang schon 2017
abend wieder für sie da machen sie es
denn die frage stelle sondern ich sage
ich tatsächlich für ein richtiges
die fragen der journalisten hat er nur
die nicht mehr wir haben nur ein drittel
und jetzt ist dass er derzeit ab sie
keine kinder also ich werde auf jeden
ihre eigene meinung zu sagen das ist
weiter mit ihnen frau gekühlt und yahia
diese grün-roten der damen führen
thema beschäftigt hat der kann ja
termine kürzen wie können wir
wenn es unser oberstes ziel ist das
immer noch nicht was wir jetzt bekommen
noch kein problem aufgetreten und das
höhen es gab eine forsa umfrage im mai
problem wenn anstand sich nicht mehr
militärischen ziele wer soll eigentlich
anne spiegel als familienministerin ist
entscheidung treffen das scheint mir
republik großgezogen also das war die
jetzt nochmal frankreich vor marie le
sie auch nur das fleisch leisten also
unterbreche ja ungern habe ich möchte
im grunde genommen nicht wenn ich sie
schwere waffen ja nein und vielleicht ja
es müsste eine große weltumspannende
gesagt schauen sie sich doch um das
gut
eigentlich nur noch vegan leben
schon mal sehr gut für viele nach neben
deutsch französische freundschaft sei
das sieht man schon daran also die also
fall eine verdammt schlimme ministerin
gegen wien gewinnen ja das scheint war
und das ist echt ein problem ist dass
ist toll ich verteile dafür genau also
lohnt oder in der politik sozusagen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
immer das thema manuela schwesig also
unterbrechen da da theoretisch selbst
arschkarte nummer um es mal ganz so
doch problematisch zu zahlen zumindest
ich finde auch klare moralische position
die debatte um die frauenquote ja wieder
natürlich auch noch alena gerber eine
gemetzel dort zu beenden dann reden wir
illusionär gewesen hätte frankreich nur
all das all das füllt sie und sagt also
20 21 haben sich noch 75 prozent der
ich wollte nur ganz generell sagen doch
eigentlich kann man auch jetzt schon mit
pen retten muss jahren das nennt man in
nicht mehr das prinzip ist dass man
konferenz geben das ist wie so eine frau
machen alle so wie ich oder auf konkrete
ja nicht klar und solange das nicht
ich die jungs gar nicht werden aber lena
ihren professoren riekel guru die
kann ich nur sagen will am ende ist es
sagen das war noch eine zeit wo man
würde ich darauf hinweisen wollen dass
die glaubwürdigkeit der politiker die
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
mecklenburg vorpommern die regierung hat
geschadet usw welchen kontext in dem
aussprachen kürzen und wie schützen wir
voll in gang gekommen und ich muss
frage stellen zu dem thema dann ist das
wenn am tier alles erfolgreich
über den frieden und über verhandlungen
gerade steht das würde ich ihnen gerne
frankreich dann vom republica also alle
geklärt ist ist die forderung nach
das thema passt natürlich jetzt auch
tatsächlich auch hängt es auch von jeder
dem thema besteht nämlich geruch auf
wir das bei anderen kriegen ganz egal ob
während der korona pandemien
fragen was jetzt mit schweren waffen ist
ich finde es gibt einen moralischen
deutschen für die fertigstellung von
du hast ja eine tochter ich glaube fünf
rabenmutter so auf dem gesicht eine
absolviert wurde und in deutschland sind
und dann müssten alle über diesen
über angebote die dazu führen können
thema nämlich auch schon rum und zwar
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
wenn ich dann an der macht bin dann
200.000 euro in diese stiftung
zugeben das eine spiel frauen in der
schweren waffen für mich keine
ist für mich ehrlich gesagt zu viel
geben nicht völlig dabei zu gazprom
hinzu ich lebe nicht vegan ja aber dann
in aleppo dann bagdad wo die bilder
unvergleichlicher weise leidenschaftlich
einfach nicht mehr die einfachen nicht
sehr gut weil also mich stört wahnsinnig
müssen jetzt ob sie wollen oder nicht
kontext der wahl ja und da wir jetzt ja
menschen die nicht nur kinder haben
notz dem 2 ausgesprochen das heißt sie
überschuss ich finde wir haben eine
frau ab ja also das kann man glaube ich
karte und keine kita keinen
es 7 millionen tiere die wir haben die
was jetzt mit weiteren sanktionen ist
wir haben hier die ganze über
jahre alt ist da ja du könntest also
politik und in führungspositionen einen
frieden reden unter putin will nur eines
ähnlich waren nicht getan haben und
makro wählen damit marie le pen nicht
verschwindet das alles dann verschwindet
eingezahlt und gazprom 20 millionen also
entschuldigen gesprochen was uns nervt
dann reden wir eben nicht über schwere
moralische
mehr glaubwürdig sind die nicht
auch irgendwo nicht so ganz
relativ denn ein moralischer eine
für die freiheit kämpfte und dafür
um es nur der up dazu übergangen lasst
sondern vielleicht auch einen
mach doch mal so der züchter na dann mal
hatte auch gegen den willen der
generalisieren ich kenne frauen die sie
hat er ausweichend oder gar nicht
waffen das wäre nur ein punkt holen wir
regiert das ist natürlich für die
echten bärendienst erwiesen hat indem
sterne millionen ist man sich nur in
nächstes jahr im januar eigentlich 60
ich hab's gelöst mit 250 prozent einsatz
dass man dann doch lieber zurücktritt
klärt außer dies erklärt das mit mehr
der verlangt eigentlich und das ist
insofern habe ich ja nur gesagt was sind
ich wundere mich nur dass diese pipeline
diese die sind menschen die nicht
laut ich könnte heute werden bei
so eine verlogene entschuldigungs kultur
pflegebedürftigen angehörigen oder
eintrat an meiner seite die legendäre
bevölkerung handeln müssen und auch
verantwortung übernehmen die ihre
das geht tatsächlich eher gd es geht um
geantwortet klar ist olaf scholz will
den leuten noch mal den spaß wir sehen
mit einem kind überfordert ich kenne
gibt's denn irgendeine floskel die dich
jahre élysée vertrag feiert also deutsch
französische linke fast inakzeptabel vor
einmal doch frau regina ich meine ja
deutschland deutschland ist das
die kriegsziele weil was putin sagt das
waffen und mehr geld für mehr waffen
sie nämlich gezeigt hat wie es nicht
hierher gehören dann haben wir wieder
bitte als schülerin habe ich komme aus
geschichte jetzt in dieser kriegs
wozu eigentlich ja gerne gazprom
bundes chefredakteurin vertrieb jährige
zweitstärkste land nach frankreich
ministerin werden was hältst du denn von
vielleicht ein pferd oder ich weiß nicht
gegen den willen ihres vorgesetzten ja
ja also punktlosen gehabt gab ja auch
meinung mal ganz schnell ändern wenn es
da etwas was eigentlich vertrag ist in
frauen die am fünf kinder und arbeiten
so richtig nervt im jahr 2022 bei den
wenn jemand was zur berichterstattung
französische freundschaft ist das
glaube ich der hauptgrund der verlangt
noch mehr krieg und leid geschehen wird
übrigens selbst wenn dieser versuche
allen dingen zum zweiten mal das heißt
geht fielmann kind und karriere nicht
die ukraine nicht so unterstützen wie
die wir jetzt gerade in der politik
eine echte französische kultur und das
ist mir klar und das höre ich und ich
einem landkreis da ist sehr viel
nun auch familien quote er finde ich
eine welle von empathie und eine welle
keine andere lösung wenn man muss dann
als 20 jahre lang hat sie entschieden
stiftung wird sein ist eine gazprom
sagen kann dann ja wohl frau riekel ja
natürlich eine ankündigung die
nebenbei voll beruf will ich noch nicht
auseinandersetzung auf einmal zum
was schlimmer ist ganz egal warum alle
ab und zu gern hören die alle keine
der politik bei den journalisten deren
die zeitenwende erfordert wo sollen denn
massentierhaltung und ich habe als
erleben da geht es um die
sage noch mal dass ich weder den
eine wahl die sich eigentlich in einem
macht man mal was er mache ja aber wie
politikern ja es wurde der politiker
einen kotau eine eine verbeugung der
eigentlich jeden in diesem lande also in
unter einen hut bekommt das ist schade
wahnsinnig spannend das thema und ich
überschüssen die die noch rauchen und zu
alle erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurden
stiftung und jetzt hat sie diese engen
hier würde ich gern noch einmal paare
riesengroßen thema wird das ganze fing
die ukraine ist braucht er hat gesagt
ahnung hatten denn dann wird er und sein
job ist es doch gerade abweichende
wer in der gesellschaft das sagen hat
glaubt man einfach wenn man nicht in der
schülerin weil ich daran da kann ich
menschen haben irgendwelche die meisten
politischen spektrum abspielen sollte
angriffskrieg entschuldige noch dass ich
von gefühlen mit der ein strategisches
ziehe unglaublich meinen hut vor dir
deutschland in diesem fall zucken lassen
ich muss schon sagen dass ich ihnen sehr
ronzheimer zurückholen bei der frage was
heißt noch lange nicht dass sie am
da der normale bürger vertrauen haben
war das sind natürlich ich möchte nicht
soll die frau kommen und auf einmal muss
du das eben gesagt hast ja das fieber
kommt oft der satz wir müssen uns
mehr verdienen als auf dem tennisplatz
an 2010 ich erinnere mich gerne dass ich
russland-politik und es geht natürlich
meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
und ein zitat von ihnen frau riekel kann
die ukrainische soldaten ich übersetze
menschen durch gehen und eine der
verlangt irgend etwas womit er dann nach
müsste weil deutschland frankreich
yvonne weil wir haben ja gerade wechsel
rechts links konservativ grünen die auch
menschen die ich kenne haben hier keine
den aggressor hier er rechtfertige noch
geschehen beurteilt wird teilweise in
nahe bin
das hat sie einfach maximal tragisch
sie die ahnung haben ich entschuldige
kontakte hat sie dann so ein bisschen
habe ich bei einer hühnerzucht
geschissen jahre ist schon auch die
kind war kein argument nicht glücklich
ehrlich machen und zwar immer genau an
hauptstadt lebt glaubt man das glaube
doch auch richtig gut
schon so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen
also in frankreich nicht das monokel ja
sind die militärischen kriegsziele die
bin der professorin für europa
häufigsten versuche ist zum beispiel
kenne sie aber ist ja irgendwo ja das
auch um die spd aber auch um die cdu und
ich besonders treffend bei meiner
verantwortung es gibt auch habe
das einmal frei die seien zu blöd um die
immer wird zu einer wahl zwischen system
scheidung was heißt das für europa das
frage warum es aber raum haben wir diese
deutschen medien so kommt es mir vor
was heißt russland darf diesen krieg
wie du das hättest du hast zwei kinder
dem punkt an dem es wirklich zu spät ist
beiseitegewischt dann tauchten dokumente
sie ist ministerpräsident ja das ist ja
schwangere tiere zwangs zu füttern mit
wissenschaft und ja die ersten artikel
dass sich der ukraine eine schuld
ich sehr gerne und ein anderes will
einer siegesrede prahlen unter ruf
im job zu sein ja ich möchte dass keine
frau gerade im raum gestellt hat paul
recherche natürlich auch über sieht das
gearbeitet allerdings nur zwei tage dann
gezeigt sie war total überlastet das
relativ ungefiltert ukrainische position
sogenannten unteren schichten sagen
heißt wir sind tatsächlich wir wären
und also ich langsam nicht mehr hören
deutschen panzer zu fahren das würde
eigentlich auf eric schmidt ist doch
verteidigen gegen systemkritik und das
zuschieben aber was sind die
es gibt viele gründe es gibt gelb westen
ihnen nicht sehr bindet mehr und ein
fünf und sieben jahre alt sind wie und
geschrieben habe um gesagt habe dass
finde ich aber ein ganz schönes
vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz also in
wünschen was in der lehrer nicht
auf die zeigen wie nahe doch diese
schlusswort zu dem thema weil das ist
lassen wo sie sind ja warum könnt ihr
plötzlich erklären alle nachdem sie
das ist schon jetzt mal umsatz des
dann erwarten wir von ihr mehr als von
jetzt zu lange dauert also deswegen
nichts ist klar nein ich natürlich nicht
tatsächlich betroffen im markt auch
nicht gewinnen
chemikalien substanzen aus
europäischen in diesem fall europäischen
spazieren kann denn er ist kein mann der
kann mich ganz schnell auf den
verändert und das sollte sich auch leser
gemeinsamer feiern gepunktet auch immer
bisher verwenden versehen fünf und zehn
geht böse aus weil immer wenn die
hätte einem mann übrigens auch passieren
jahres und ich bin da ganz bei ihnen
ist als solches im prinzip schon so eine
tennisplatz zurück sehr reumütig dann
soziale gründe in frankreich die stadt
ja damit will ich weder irgendetwas
der wir ganz nennen doch das ist übliche
nur noch im lidl einkaufen warum haben
jahrelang so eine kungelei betriebe am
beobachter darin bin ich nun mal nicht
kosmetikprodukten und dann guckt dann
dass weitere scherze muss ich sofort
beziehung zwischen ihrer regierung und
diese panzer nicht er hat außerdem
eigentlich das was der richtige ist
deutschen was alleine mit den russen
was bedeutet das jetzt wird russland
können aber der eindruck ist nun mal
unserer so zusammen staatsräson
kriegsziele wollen wir die russisch
mutter stellt sich immer sehr stark als
ja ich bin da relativ sprachlos
all ihren vorgängig ich rede jetzt nicht
jahre alt also schon halben teenager es
aufgeben und das ist meine große große
sie kein vernünftiges einkommen hin
erosion von demokratie einmal zwei
frau riekel ich finde auch die
geeignet ich glaube besser konnte man
jeder muss für sich selbst entscheiden
hat sich verändert wenn ich das
musste man hühner ausstellen da leben
zurücknehmen aber es gibt viele menschen
andrack träger
machen ja von rapallo über hitler stalin
hängen geblieben eine frau mit kindern
danach tötet man es tierchen man schnell
land spaltung also wie wenigen städte
eigentlich immer fragen was fasziniert
warum sind sie nicht mitgekommen bei der
wollen wir russland besiegen wollen wir
gesagt dass man weitere schwere waffen
entschuldigen noch irgendetwas machen
macht nicht gerade einfacher und
ob man berufstätig sein wir ob man nicht
ort davon habe ich jetzt das tut mit
beurteilen kann was heute ja dass zum
von ihren vorgängern die kann man kaufen
zahlen zu nennen es haben über 60
sich nie für diese sendung wir wissen
konsequenzen die wir alle miteinander in
den bach auf und ziert alles und guckt
ehrlicher sah ehrlicherweise denn die
und putin war was ich also es gab
nicht gewinnen heißt es aus der ukraine
bis heute ist es immer schief gegangen
drei hühner in einem käfig der so groß
mutter in den vordergrund und sagt ich
hat es nicht gepackt und das ist
ausdrücken ich hatte meinen beifahrer
lohnentwicklung warum haben wir die in
lyon paris theorie funktionieren mit
ehrenamtlich sich zum beispiel auch in
große sorge ich bin ja sonst immer so
wie das ja sozusagen auch insinuiert
das einzige was ich sage ist dass man
verbringt die halbe woche hier liegt
ob man kinder jeder soll es machen wie
aus deutschland eben nicht einsetzen
beispiel eine universitäten frauenquote
diesen ganz ehrlich sagen hipster
schlecht für alle frau mit kindern und
die menschen denn an frau le pen sehr
gewinnt meine sympathie meine
unserem berufsleben oder in unserem
leid habe ich mich geirrt
prozent der franzosen kein vertrauen
kriegsziele gerade von wladimir putin
dass wir heute abend dabei sind last but
urban oliven und das land drumherum
werde für eure gleichstellung kämpfen
zwischen einer strategischen diskussion
eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
wird das war ja jetzt vor ein paar tagen
eine rasant schnelle imposante karriere
wie ein din a4 blatt dann muss man sie
ein bisschen wie wie als verb aarons
ja dass der fehler von gazprom war von
wie diese substanzen auf das baby und
veganen irgendwas tritt nicht
will er hat nicht mehr das in den mund
der politik ehrenamtlich um andere
gender gerecht und so weiter es hat sich
privaten kreisen tragen müssen die
wirklich genügend kritiker und sie hat
sind ja klar frau büro die hat gesagt er
er möchte das ist ein sehr schönes
machen zitat gesagt dass menschen
und wurde gleich hatte noch nie eine
ich brauchte diese ganze misere wäre
diese große eskalation über beiden
über die dinge die hier diskutiert
spritpreise alles ist dann thema
mehr in ihre regierung und in ihren
sich darum niemand tut es federer
not least yvonne weiß sie ist die
genommen aus sicht der ukraine aus der
hammer würde er hier sitzen bin ich ja
mitgenommen ja also das ist asozial ist
hin während dein mann zu hause
auf die mutter gewürgt haben und das
bewunderung ja gehört diesen tapfer
anfang an dass wir die polen nicht
ganz viel geändert ich war
erwarten politiker recht selten und das
raus heben und dann bindet man so
nachträge politisch paritätischer aber
werden und das sind viele dinge ja da
geschichten lieben die im netz gehen
menschen kümmern und in dem fall muss
wenn er die these macht deswegen ich
wollen wir einen regime change wollen
nicht passiert wenn wir an statt einer
stellvertretende chefredakteurin der
staat also kein system vertrauen mehr
schlusswort und damit kommen wir jetzt
migration großes thema seit jahren also
will die ukraine vernichten die ukraine
bis zuletzt hat sie versucht daran
und insofern würde ich da das moralische
frauenbeauftragte an der universität in
eingespannt wird und er macht das mit
perspektive der ukraine am tag als
befragt haben dass wir die litauer dass
heißt aber noch lange nicht dass dieses
menschenketten man ahnt schon was am
menschen lieben menschen das haben sie
habe ihn schon wieder im oft gehört und
keine persönlichen konsequenzen daraus
bin ich unglaublich und ausgeglichen vor
geht es um das münster abkommen und den
zu alena gerber die sich obwohl auch um
produkt jemals an einer schwangeren frau
wir sozusagen das wiederholen was die
festzuhalten
männern in der ukraine ganz klar aber
frauenquote eine familien quote hätten
die politik einfach die arbeitsweise
österreich wo ich war inzwischen ist an
ja- und bei den ganzen anderen waren die
ende der menschenkette kommt ja aber
man muss da ganz klar ist eigentlich
erfolg und wir haben gerade darüber
wir die ukraine nicht gefragt haben wir
sie über rassismus antisemitismus alles
sie geben aber ich glaube vor allem auf
würde jetzt noch einmal sam rüber
hat aufsicht wladimir putins kein
ukrainisch-russischen konflikt um ge um
statement auch nicht machen wollen aber
dieses land erneut eine großoffensive
und jetzt sagt sie naja unter den
ich erwarte einfach von politikern ja
zugelassen werden kann also im grunde
auch ein großes interesse sagt was ist
gesprochen dass man quasi von haus aus
muss so gestaltet werden dass es nicht
amerikaner in bagdad 2003 gemacht haben
abendblatt reporterin und auch noch
scheiden zur erwiderung habe
zieht und da ist manuela schwesig leider
auch darüber sprechen das ist einfach
dem dorf stellung auf dem land wo man
hätten ja auch eine pipeline bauen
den universitäten sogar schon so dass
allem das ehrlich machen dann denkt man
diese tiere sind ja folge punkt mit
klar das muss eigentlich abgeräumt
existenzrecht er hat gesagt er will tier
wir gesehen haben in frankreich also
die krim und was auch immer da geht es
dann hätte zum beispiel nur ein beispiel
drauf hat gerade auf dem land hat le pen
die kinder bestimmt sorgen aber
können die irgendwie nicht von russland
immer auch unter vor der politiker die
genommen gibt es schon längst viel
wenn ich eine mutter wäre
nicht fair für mich richtig wohl ist die
dieses diese domain marine le pen
ja immer erst mal davon ausgeht die mama
einfach sagen wir wollen alle probleme
man zwischen dem akademischen und dem
24 stunden job ist sondern genau um das
heute liegen ihr besonders die reporter
wäre das eine realistische zielsetzung
regional waren kommunalwahl sind
antibiotika die sind total so aggressiv
werden also die tiere diese ganzen
egal frau der man erwarte ich einfach
über sich ergehen lassen muss im osten
bestimmte zusagen mehr um die tiere sie
aber auch im amerikanisch chinesische
nach deutschland geht sondern wo danach
ja ich habe so ein bisschen das gefühl
ganze zeit gelogen augen
günstigere methoden und viele humaneren
übernehmen er hat gesagt hier will er
heutigen stand müssen stand hätte ich
biologischen alter unterscheidet das
macht das alles der papa wird sogar
jacke punktgenau ist er überall
teilweise bei den letzten kommunalwahlen
aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
anton hofreiter familie minister werden
und große reportagen am herzen hinter
das sind die fragen und diese fragen
interessen um erdöl und -gas usw und
die menschen sterben in mariupol kinder
schädigungen und ich würde sagen es hat
ich glaube das liegt auch wirklich
habe ich mich nicht alles macht so an
die man die man in frankreich auf dem
und ich wüsste mein sohn musste camp
unterscheidet sie sich überhaupt nicht
heißt wenn man ein kind hat kriegt man
und dann irgendwann überhaupt keinen
methoden aber sie kommen einfach sie
dass ich nicht mal führte nach acht
konsequenzen wenn ich einen fehler mache
gelobt wenn er einmal im büro zu einem
würden sich doch eltern viel eher
2020 60 prozent nicht zur wahl gegangen
opel warschau nach was auch immer wer
hingekommen in die dörfer hat sich über
sein das ist sein land erst gesagt das
legt einfach mal los
mich wenn ich das war ich damals anders
können der hat nämlich einen sohn und
an rechnungs punkte usw
mehr mit lobbyismus zu tun als mit der
bock mehr auf hähnchen also das gleiche
land zu glaubt zu spüren hängen in
halbwegs diszipliniert und nüchtern zu
uns liegt ein bewegter nachrichten tag
von der politischen elite in wie sie so
diesem punkt an dem ich in die ecke
dass man das sozusagen
treten gar nicht in kraft weil diese
und frauen eingeschlossen sind ein
geschaltet bin sondern weil ein oster
kümmern und sich nicht mehr dafür
dazwischen ist wo die auch gas bekommen
mein thema heute aber ist dass ich finde
mit linked lich kommt wenn das baby
ist russland also die ganz ziele
entschieden und das ist auch so eine
gedrängt wurde jetzt mache ich mich aber
verwerflichkeit der leute ja das müsste
all blicken lassen hat extrem stark auf
an der ländliche bevölkerung das ist ja
sein das heißt man kann gar nicht mehr
auch männer können sich ja um
das an unregulierten habe man in
russische truppen haben mit der
muss ich dazu stehen und ich muss auch
chemiekalien gesetze und agenturen die
frage ob sozusagen vegan die antwort ist
deutscher bundeskanzler der sich dorthin
friedens naschen
gerade ein bisschen fieber wir mütter
das scheint vielen das zuschauen weil
einsetzen dass sie sehen das noch
hineingehen ich würde meinen sohn packen
unabhängigen dann diskutieren können
formuliert von wladimir putin sind
dann wäre das ein europäisches land war
gleichberechtigung und familienpolitik
diskutieren ohne in den moralischen
floskel ja weil ich finde in so einem
irgendeiner form mit ausländern zusammen
erwarteten offensive im osten der
ermessen dass die franzosen von ihrem
die frauen gesetzen und makro hat sich
tierversuche müssen umgehend gestoppt
reagiert die politische elite gibt ja
man noch mal austarieren aber es könnte
wir werden gar nicht gefragt wir wir
wir haben letztens auch ein leserbrief
probleme einfach jeden teilnehmer ein
stellt und eigentlich nichts zu
ähnlich über trump wer also in
und würde mit ihnen auswandern oder
brasilien was ich sagen würde ist wir
kommen einfach nicht runter von ihrem
ja so wenn dann oh ja ich will ich will
überschuss zu gehen dass in kiew
völlig klar und wenn sie sagen keiner
auf massentierhaltung oder ob die anfang
ja die kriege die besetzen unsere jobs
ukraine begonnen unser bundeskanzler
müsste hallo nicht sofort meldet ich
kann diese friedens thesen naiven
fall muss man eine persönliche
kümmern jetzt ist es lisa paus die wird
sogar sein dass dieses gesetz noch mal
bekommen dass man wenn ein politiker
die konsequenzen tragen und dass das ist
hohen ross und dabei sind sich quasi
system praktisch schon genervt sind also
werden alleine in europa leiden jedes
sonst wohin gehen ich alles aus mir
letzter entschuldige dass das problem
dort nämlich nicht blicken lassen sie
haben keine möglichkeit ich du wir alle
washington und new york hätte niemand
verkünden hat der hätte das sein lassen
ist weniger jain früher einfach mal dass
ich will nur sagen wenn es ein
müssen uns trotzdem auflösen es geht
wieder das wort ehrlich machen sagt man
tragischerweise nicht nur kiew in der
nur das zu was sie nicht mehr
olaf scholz hat heute abend um 18 uhr
will über frieden sprechen doch würde
gibt peter sucht gerade über eine
gerade zwei gesetzte denn wir haben ja
aber gerade noch arrogant und ist nicht
verantwortung übernehmen das ist ganz
sich als alleinerziehende natürlich auch
europäisches projekt gewesen wäre ja
jahr neun millionen tiere sie leiden
muss ich nein nein frau am ende geht es
nicht nur um die politik es geht auch um
angenommen dass trump gewinnt das hat
dass der wahlgang fast schon zwei häuser
wir haben keine möglichkeit wir müssen
geht doch nicht nur familien an sondern
die machen sich hier breit die zerstören
friedens diesen vorteil das klingt alles
in der politik irgendwie nicht so
der das sein dass müssen am ende auch
einen drink nehmen sollte als dem spiel
er am tag cyber war klar es gibt ein ei
millionen unterschriften
verheimlichen kann und in dem fall hat
mir seelands die der ukrainische
spricht dass sich die journalistin
dieses gesetz von 2013 und wir haben die
aufgetreten deshalb hat sie jetzt einen
ukraine tragischerweise menschen sterben
die finanzen finanzmärkte es geht um
wichtig auch unsere politiker sind ja
sehr gut kümmern aber diesen ganzen
pünktlich zur arbeit erscheint ein viel
nicht nur sie werden zu tode gequält im
verbreitet freundlich nur ein ungenau
dann wäre das ein anderes projekt dann
ein kleiner trend der sich doch ab 24
präsident will ständig über frieden
sondern dass mir spricht eine frau
zu sonntag und nicht irgendwie morgens
wahnsinnig toll aber und wir machen auch
ansonsten könnte es sein dass
wenn wir hingegen höher gefallen wir
und vor allem wenn man dann einen blick
unsere kultur
auch jeden menschen also jede person hat
vorteil davon 35.000 kommunen sind 22
umweg über eine spiegel hätten wir uns
hier nur um eine sache es geht nicht
gehe da wo macht und geld ist ja also es
darüber möchten wir sofort mit ihnen
manuela schwesig hat ja
uhr ist noch in deutschland wenn ich das
auch leitfiguren und in der in der
bundes kind ist keine ausrede also
das scheint mir tatsächlich das gebot
sozusagen di anima das bewahrende und
würde das heute auch nicht dann würde
rahmen von tierversuchen jetzt mag der
sprechen er sagt immer wieder seit
deutschland dieses gesetz eben noch
chemikalie vereinigung und die beißen
die belästigen unsere frauen ja das sind
er ist der heroin in den irgendwie in
am netz und keine ahnung war es ja noch
auf die spd macht die anstatt sich mit
einen riesenfehler dass ist dieser
so sagen darf nicht wirklich anders in
weil also es kribbelt mir zu sagen dass
glaube ich sparen können wenn also schon
bleiben in der aussenpolitik und kommen
auch im privatleben und dieses
darum was in linz war was auf der krim
deutschland nicht so unter druck stehen
sprechen dafür schalten wir nämlich bild
geht im prinzip um vorstände um die
meinem job sie würden mit den vogel
beginn des krieges ich bin bereit mich
einmal entschärft und tierversuche
als geschätzt so unterwerfen gekommen
der stunde und die zurückhaltung ja um
arten in der ersten wahl an marie le pen
den usa warum hat man schwamm gewählt
irrglaube den jahrzehntelang auf die
eine oder andere denken tierversuche
sich aber des tieres wohl wird einfach
aktiv an diesem nord stream 2 mit gebaut
zeigen während ein mann da quasi noch
justiz gilt ja das prinzip nichtwissen
eine quote dann bitte eine familien
das natürlich ein phänomen ist was jetzt
dass diese pipeline jetzt das zentrale
privatleben braucht man auch in der
große unternehmen natürlich und die
sich selbst zu beschäftigen nämlich mit
war was china oder die usa machen
das sind ganz primitive reaktionen und
ich liebe das leben und ich möchte dass
vize paul ronzheimer dazu er seit über
mit putin an einen tisch zu setzen dass
nochmal viel einfacher durchgeführt
sind doch illegalen das dachte ich auch
diese diskrepanz noch mal zu machen die
ich habe heute mit einer freundin
jetzt natürlich sofort zu frauenbüro und
den wäldern und feldern weit weg von den
ist gesund und sie erlauben alle einig
tatsächlich etwas älter ist ja ich
frauen überall ja die hilfskräfte die
weil man beiden ich wollte also der
eine kleine runde applaus bekommt wenn
nach wie vor ist kleiner angesehen und
werden können also jeder der sich jetzt
sozusagen gegenstand ist wenn es um
politik um anregungen zu bekommen um
den fragen was eigentlich in der spd los
quote denn dann würde sich auch endlich
sondern es geht darum dass russland hier
medien geprägt hat wladimir putin will
schützt nicht vor strafe ich kann nicht
nun niemand mehr sterben muss und ich
2013 trat das gesetz in kraft es wird
uns verhandelt schon vor dem krieg hat
telefoniert aus paris und jetzt hatte
zwei monaten in kiew paulis wurden heute
pflegekräfte die krankenschwestern die
es dann trotzdem schaffst du für die
punkt ist dass wir natürlich in
erinnere mich auch noch an herrn zeitz
das wird einfach totgeschwiegen ich als
dass diese tierquälerei nicht geht ja
die fehlt mit tatsächlich in der
zum beispiel etwas engagieren möchte
die haben dann macht sie
marine le pen ja ich dachte ich bringe
deutschland noch so ein
von den hauptstädten und ich glaube das
dieses thema geht ja das will ich nur
einen angriffskrieg führt gegen ein
einfach sagen habe ich nicht gewusst zu
fragen familien quote alena
ich zittere geradezu vorsonntag weil es
er gesagt das darf nicht passieren darf
der regen zwei koffer irgendwie auf
obwohl es viele
war in den letzten jahrzehnten in den
andere meinungen kennenzulernen um nicht
schlecht bezahlten jobs wie auch immer
endverbraucher steht bevorstehe
ja nur respekt der bürger nur so ein
berichterstattung aber scholz hat das
der kern des dilemmas vielleicht einmal
steuerversprechen und kaufte sich so
aber ich würde nur gerne mal sagen dass
allerdings zunichte gemacht kleinen
haben einen schutzvertrag sowie boris
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
verhältnismäßigkeit zwar recht haben
schwere kämpfe aus kleinstädten im don
letzten jahren gehen sie auf den
etwas und direkt vegan zu werden könnte
souveränes land es geht darum dass
einem bahnsteig 1996 als damaliger
um diese frauen kümmert sich ja keiner
ist auch so in frankreich ja die
sagen insofern bin ich völlig entspannt
vorprodukten weiß überhaupt nicht ich
es keinen krieg zwischen bruder völkern
mal ein bisschen europa oder
auch noch stimmen es geht auch um die eu
ukraine was ein schrecklicher gedanke
könnte wirklich sein dass wir so eine
gute kommt sozusagen im gesamten
nur in dieser blase in dieser politik
bisschen den kotau des westens nein
heimlich still und leise von der
ja aber es geht da wo es sozusagen immer
ziel doch heute ganz klar formuliert
weswegen sich das nicht so artikuliert
außenpolitik mit in die sendung obwohl
ukrainischen botschafter los und das ist
zumindest diese petition unterschreiben
was gemeldet wie ist die lage
geben also wenn man jetzt versucht
becker ich hab gar nicht auf die
auflösen denn die quote ist ja nur ein
war schockiert bei meiner recherche wie
innenminister zurückgetreten ist weil er
russland die ukraine angegriffen hat es
ich habe das damals schon für einen
wie sie in der realität aussehen könnte
franzosen haben ein ganz anderes im
art donald trump in weiblich jetzt
ist diesen krieg gewinnen kann sie kann
kritiker gab die davon gewarnt haben es
europäischen chemikalienagentur die
russland darf nicht gewinnen das hat er
natürlich leid es war wirklich nur ich
blase zu leben und deswegen finde ich
wladimir putin hat ganz klar gesagt also
fehler gehalten dass wir das so
verträge geschaut zu dafür will ich
landwirtschaftspolitik weil sie lange
die peter aktuelle ins leben gerufenes
viele kosmetik giganten nach wie vor
nicht passt oder klatschten am beispiel
natürlich verantwortung als minister
lobbyismus der politik praktisch nicht
das ja hier mich so oft der fall ist
sozusagen die schuld bei der ukraine
ausdruck des problems nämlich der nicht
ihn stoppen sie kann den verlangsamen
demnächst bekommen ja und die wird
sozusagen und deutschkurs sich mäßig
wirklich kaum noch zu glauben
geht darum dass wladimir putin mit
sehe nur den autismus wächst und genau
hieß es ja und der eu
migrationsproblem als wir die haben
nicht zu stellen sodass als kind nicht
von frau spiegel ist da wo man jegliche
der befürchtete horror im osten lena der
weiterhin fordert dass gewisse substanz
gesagt und man kann ja auch nicht
tiere töten bewusst töten 4 millionen
vor wir können darüber aufregen werden
aber die franzosen wählen jetzt am
oder den westlichen partnern zu nutzen
okay bemerkte man müsste sie einfach um
also die empfehlung dass das nur noch
august ich möchte einen ganz praktischen
natürlich die eu von innen heraus
vereinbarkeit von beruf und familie
ist ja auch eine hochpolitische sache
haben das auch zu spüren und in den
seiner sich die ukraine russland ist und
landwirtschaftspolitik hat viel
behaupten dass die bundesrepublik jetzt
und wir und wenn neue waffen kommen wird
seinen truppen hier kriegsverbrechen
sonntag zum zweiten mal zweiter wahlgang
machen klar hat die spd eine große
polizeibeamte irgendwas nicht gemacht
die landwirtschaft reden wir können über
das müsste man doch erstmal an verlangt
richtig ghettos wo
verantwortung hat meistens viel verdient
nur benutzt werden dürfen wenn sie an
gelernt weil ich tennis spielen musste
kaputtgemacht also sowohl die milchkühe
ländern wo ist deswegen großbritannien
wärme schlageter möchte einen ganz
zerstören also ich finde diese frau
dafür bekannt wäre dass wir in letzter
es geht um marie le pen oder makro und
ändern dann hätten auch väter die chance
begeht und wenn sie sagen und soll ich
haben ja das gehört der damals zum guten
familie von familie zählt bei der
tieren getestet werden und ich finde das
das aufgeklappte hinzuschauen und auch
elternschaft hat ja eher karriere tod
war er
er ist zu allem bereit er lässt die
tiere werden in deutschland jedes jahr
praktischen vorschlag machen zu ihr zu
unter umgehung der ukraine und vielen
tradition reichten man kann auch noch
keine ahnung was impfstoffe zum beispiel
die wo im kranken halt leben und und
meistens viel prestige hat ja und da ist
der normandie aber auch unten die
zeit total übereilt gehandelt hätten
usa und frankreich in ländern wo man sah
deiner fragen direkt auch mal an frau
wirklich gefährlich deshalb handelt es
direkt nach der sage nach deren geburt
also ich
ton ich würde ihr völlig recht geben
es noch schrecklicher weil putin ja
kümmern was es für bilder gibt und dass
ihrem thema er muss es sein noch eine
regionen erobern er will mario puzo muss
aprikosen und die ganzen 40 anbauten ja
deswegen finde ich eigentlich weil ich
wladimir putin zu schauen und zu sehen
mal dran erinnern egon bahr vena das
sich meiner ansicht nach hier nicht nur
ja schon gehabt ich meine man wollte so
ost ländern ist diese gas pipeline hat
menschen hinrichten die frauen werden
reden ja
es ist natürlich schon eine
guru weitergeben und zwar ist es denn
diese frauengeschichte dann so richtig
jedoch allein 72 stunden 100 milliarden
berufung in ein höheres politisches und
dass dieser begriff von anstand dass man
ist ein absolutes unding ich hab sogar
ohne kinder patricia mayr hat die
die unterlaufen einigen tests die sozis
was hier eigentlich passiert dass ein
bringt es leider oftmals mit sich oder
nicht sagt oh gott jetzt kommen die
schicksalswahl weil wir sind ja als
waren damals die großen sozusagen
frauen in die vorstände frauen in den
wenn moralische überhöhung dann verstehe
minute frau rieke veröffentlichen wir
wir können über alles mögliche reden
um eine frankreich war sondern auch um
sehr dünne trapp nicht das lipid beiden
bin ich finde die frau schwesig
man es sagen das machen das was er hier
eine eigene kleine firma gegründet ich
vergewaltigt kinder werden umgebracht
und wenn sie so ein französischer bauer
zu bewilligen aus einem sondervermögen
eigentlich richtig keine weiteren
ihm hier ein amt ausfüllt in bestem
waffen hoch jetzt muss ich aber aufhören
nur noch das habe ich das sage ja wenn
verstehe der sowjet republik ich finde
kriegsverbrecher büro ich habe das
bester deutsch französischer partner in
sind und von der eu
erfüllen sie nicht uns 4 millionen tiere
wurde zeuge davon dass produkte
eine deutschland war denn jetzt
doch diese firmen diese kosmetikfirmen
zumindest karriereknick und ich kann
finanzmarkt was auch immer das auch in
nicht geschafft hat was wir ihnen liebe
sängerin geht im quote weil eine quote
aber wenn es dafür und darum geht so das
wissen und gewissen der republik ja und
landwirtschaftspolitik enttäuscht sind
nein er wird immer härter und furchtbar
eigentlich und eine interessante figur
das ist die realität und zusagen
schweren waffen zu liefern in die
wie ich mir ja immer
wir schon eine quote haben habe ich
dieser partnerschaft europa mit dem
uns natürlich noch enger an russland
werden sofort in die mülltonne gekippt
ihre chancen weil wir einfach viel zu
es ja auch interessant dass heute
ich die welt nicht mehr natürlich muss
studieren
das ist eigentlich noch gar nicht für
den universitäten sind werden längst
gesehen in den straßen von butscher wie
und dann kommt marie le pen und sagt ich
problem ist also strukturell dass man
gesagt dann wäre besser eine
ukraine
der öffentlichen güter dieser republik
günstiger hergestellt werden wenn sie an
herangeführt und da gab es auch genug
franzosen aufs engste verbunden ein
das kümmern das was hier menschen
unflexibel
zuschauer immer wieder gezeigt haben und
verstehen was negatives ist eine putin
und sie hat ja auch super wahl gewonnen
und brutale reagieren was ist ja wenn
das ist mein ernst frey millioen 417
wenn ich habe gerade tatsächlich gedacht
wladimir putin muss man nur irgendwie
die auch die immer noch tierversuche
die bundeswehr wurde die bundeswehr
noch nicht bei zehn prozent ja und da
familienmutter als eine frauen die frau
also ich sag mal ich bin jetzt an der
dass das abhanden gekommen ist also frau
bin gegen die eu das ist auch noch
kommt lasse stehe ich auch ein
die menschen dort hingerichtet wurden
weil diese außenpolitik von ihr so
hier sind als braucht also nicht
tieren getestet werden und das finde ich
sozusagen am guten und am weniger
hingerichtet werden wir wollen dass die
kamen sie denn das für ein auftritt von
leute die gewarnt haben und die frau
populistischer sozusagen wahlsieg in
hier weil es ist die offensive gab die
verstehe ist was schlecht ist obwohl
und ich finde jetzt müsste sie
kompletter jander und gleicher weise
ist ein generelles problem da bin ich
interessante boden wir werden auf jeden
vielleicht auf einer friedenskonferenz
zwingend mehr frauen sondern vor allem
millionen tiere werden jedes jahr
spiegel muss ja gerade so aus dem amt
dass es zum leben aber aber ich glaube
von wladimir putins truppen mit händen
die vor spielt den fenstern uns frauen
durchführen ich könnte ihnen einen
lieferketten gesetze auch gutes beispiel
universität bonn ja da ist bertha von
verstehen ist ja nicht was gutes wie
muss im jahr 22 einfach aufhören tiere
die ukraine am ende
irgendwo einbinden also ja
eigentlich zumindest also erstmal müsste
olaf scholz also ich fand zb hat ein
dabei dieses problem ist mehr lösen ob
menschen lassen sie mich bitte ausreden
nationalistisch geradezu rassistisch die
frankreich ist sicherlich was anderes
soldaten uns hier einkesseln wollten das
mehr väter und mütter an der spitze des
geschlachtet
auch ob wie hier ich finde das wort
gedrängt werden so ein bisschen ja hat
weil ich eine frau bin deswegen habe ich
direkteren nennen nach war jeweilige
ja wir können auch alle mal irgendwie
auch immer was ich nur sagen will ist an
echt ein ei gelegt
nach hinten wie sie hingerichtet wurden
fall das thema ist ihm vertrauen hier
suttner die erste frau den
703 millionen tiere erfüllen quasi diese
schwesig hat wie auch glaube ich frau
lassen sie mich bitte ausreden ich habe
fast zerstört ist unzählige menschen tot
als sagen wir mal ungarn oder polen ja
sie alles offenlegen musste zurücktreten
ein t shirt statt 5 t shirts kaufen dann
satz gesagt da hat mich sehr bewegt weil
sicher geklammert ohne ende aber das
sind genauso viel wert wie menschen und
haben sie nicht geschafft und das
wir das nur mit makoto damit einer
weil sie auch so weinerlich war und uns
hält auch gar nichts von deutschland ich
system vertrauen ganz spannend frage
friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat für den
staates und den unternehmen weil sie
da einen
dieser pipeline war glaube ich die
merkel gesagt na ja das ist ein rein
kunden das ist manchmal die namen und
gleiche versuchen sie jetzt im dom bass
sie auch ausreden lassen dass hier
nicht aus den augen verlieren damit es
kriterien an denen kann man dann munter
da haben wir ja schon populisten in der
weil sie zivilisten weil sie männer
bonus dass ich finde die quote überhaupt
das kann so nicht weitergehen
glaube auch manchmal dass sie geradezu
er nämlich gar nicht bewegen war er hat
familienkutsche lösen im zweifel zwar
satz die waffen nieder ja und ich frage
familien sicherung ist meiner ansicht
ich finde sie muss zumindest ein
dann ist es operation gelungen und
erbsünde oder die originale sünde dass
eifersüchtig ist auf die beziehung
und fröhlich los testen und 4 millionen
wäre das lieferketten gesetzt vielleicht
menschen hingerichtet werden das darf
in deutschland niemals so weit kommt wie
wann ist uns denn dieses system
waren die dort einfach gelebt haben also
kann man denn die kosmetik lobby in die
regierung aber polen und ungarn sind
ich finde die idee gut dass auf jeder
und versuchen dort die gebiete zu nehmen
gesagt ich habe mit allen gesprochen
privatwirtschaftliches unternehmen und
wenn du weißt dass heim management ist
ja dem man noch die schuld gegeben und
nach gleich zukunftssicherung und dieses
auch noch hätte nochmal eine andere
zwischen makro und merkel und sie sagt
ein totaler unsinn und ich finde man
tiere werden sofort umgebracht anstatt
mich tatsächlich wann wir anfang von
geschenkt wir müssen es lösen aber es
in frankreich ich finde nämlich schon 33
nicht in euro sind relativ kleine länder
rücktrittsangebot machen ich bin ja
sollte hinaus um
patient tot also ich finde das einfach
kosmetik packung stehen muss für dieses
auch ihren titel als ich meinen
schranken weise erst einmal kann ich
dimension insofern bin ich das soll ich
vertrauen man sieht den trend ja auch
das gerede zu sagen das wird nicht genug
das ist ehrlich gesagt eine verarschung
wir sie nicht als wir das als deutsch
uns nicht kalt lassen das darf uns in
ist ein breiteres problem und das hat
paul unser bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat
hier immer hart härter als in allen
prozent sind schon eine menge und jetzt
motto sollte eigentlich auch in jedem in
jetzt will er nicht so brutal sein habe
frieden frieden und nochmal frieden zu
ja bei jeder entscheidung die
des volkes wenn das ist es nicht dass
ausführlich und wir haben klare
dabei aber die eigentliche frage ist wie
zumindest einen plan b in erwägung zu
russisches projekt praktisch ohne
ungarn hat acht oder zehn millionen
muss das ganz anders angehen wir müssen
ihnen dann nur zustimmung alleine ich
schrecklich ich würde so gerne auch
schon in deutschland es wird ja auch
einer politischen debatte nicht kalt das
millionen millionen deutsche mütter und
produkt wurden tierversuche durchgeführt
über frieden gesprochen das kann ich
deutschland fällt habe ich ein bisschen
anderen sendungen und die zeit für die
die liste ist lang ja also wir haben
ganz viel da bin ich bei ihnen damit zu
reden ja weil wir einen ganz tragischen
man immer hoch politisch und es gab auch
gehen wir in eine ganz kurze
einwohner frankreich ist
europäisches konzept nennt gemacht haben
hier immer mehr gespalten weil es uns
kann man den lobbyismus durchbrechen
prinzipien volle unterstützung und so
ziehen für diese tiere die schon mal
sagen legt die waffen nieder aber
vor zwei stunden eine pressekonferenz
finde es unglaublich dass man in das man
ich finde sie kann nicht einfach so
unterbrechung und sind direkt danach
these ist vorbei aber wir hören uns ja
mitleid mit ihnen also soviel zum
uns fragen wie arbeitet man in der
tun wie wir über den grip den begriff
jena sei es sollte ein dreh und
wirklich nicht mehr hören wir also ich
55 750 millionen das heißt es wären
bayer card wir haben comex wir haben
nicht für die tests in von immerhin
konflikt haben es wurde ja beschrieben
meine antwort oder mein vorschlag wäre
dass den abhandlungen naja also für
wieder da mit zwei sehr spannenden
väter haben in der pandemie ihre kinder
weiter und so fort und dann hat er
gehalten und verkündet dass die
nein das darf es nicht und das sage ich
weitermachen und die der rücktritt
natürlich wenn jetzt
der arbeit verstehen was ist arbeit ja
eine große nähe von putins basis zu
werden die männlichen küken nicht wieder
angelpunkt in jedem unternehmen werden
denn morgen abend wieder und dann gibt
habe mitnichten zu keinem zeitpunkt
herrn steuer mit der mautgebühr die sind
gesagt das leid lässt niemanden kalt und
packaging ja wenn man auf jedem was auch
verbraucher die verbraucherin selber
wir haben all die bilder vor augen aber
deutschland sind die zahlen seien noch
politik das ist doch die frage es geht
stellenwert von deutschland bei ihr ja
sanktionen sehr deutliche wirkung zeigen
immer noch tiere quält ja und wenn man
fake stiftung war auch schon
ausdrücklich das darf es übrigens in
themen sie sollten also dranbleiben also
sofort beschwerde aber des eisbergs wird
es bestimmt noch mal genug zeit auch
anderer schnack ja das heißt als
macht man die heute zu hause oder nicht
in irgendeiner form sieht durchbringen
mir fehlt außer sehr vielen semantischen
gut ja ich hab's mir deswegen auch noch
alle noch im amt der
aleppo auch nicht von den bagdad auch
also wir müssen eigentlich dahin kommen
wenn wir das jetzt so eine kapitulation
gesagt dass ich der ukraine irgendwas in
entscheiden denn ich bin gegen diese
ein kosmetikprodukt drauf schreiben
ja das will ich nur sagen das war ja
und dafür hat sie aber zu dem besonders
jemals gesehen hat wie so ein hund
untersuchungsausschuss bei hann scheuer
doch nicht darum ob jetzt ein eine
wieder darüber zu sprechen herzlichen
deutscher können wir nicht sagen dass
und wie die ukraine militärisch und
er hat das so ohne jede wärme gesagt
zurücktreten soll das wird ja auch schon
nicht und in kabul auch nicht ja da der
dass diese menschenverachtende frage
mal extra guckt also hier haben
jetzt auch nach der panne die ist ja
die schuhe schieben ja ich habe nur
würde für dieses dinge sind drei über
ganzen verbote kein fleisch kein rauchen
müssen sie unterhalten und betreuen und
gerne eine sache eine sache erwähnen und
leidet werden augentropfen zum beispiel
äußerungen auch von amerikanischen
gerne kontakt ihn ja er hat sogar einen
finanziell unterstützen werden wie ist
uns die so gar nicht interessieren jetzt
kind oder karriere dass die obsolet wird
dank wie jeden abend an dich das war
käme wie würde russland reagieren wie
eher eine ansteckung umfeld sowie haben
sozusagen nur 33 er hat 33 prozent der
versucht darüber nachzudenken wie wir
punkt ist ja nur haben wir noch ist wenn
dass es mich fast sprachlos gesagten
von der cdu gefordert aber eigentlich
verstehen oder einen verstehe weil mit
zwar für das leid der tiere müssen
die haben das auch alle gesammelt kurz
zigaretten überall in der ungar etwas
deine sicht auf den heutigen auftritt
bei kosmetik sache wie in die augen
und im übrigen ist das was sie gerade
kein einfamilienhaus mehr und so weiter
ich in meinen träumen stelle ich mir vor
kind gesegnet an der spitze steht es
teil ihres wahlkampf viele galerien ich
und um diese frage kümmert sich auch
gemacht hat muss ich ehrlich sagen das
eigentlich nicht unbedingt nach polen
oder oder auch vorschlagen dass man so
von olaf scholz was ja auch deine these
gesagt haben ein gutes beispiel dafür
und haben auch wenn die die
geträufelt was sie so hunde oder auch
war ein kommunikativ starker auftritt
nach nach meiner these übernimmt
und ich baue auf die eigenverantwortung
wenn ich das jetzt hart anhört frauen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]